I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi there, everybody. Hi.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们为你带来了终极的《办公室》爱好者的播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，带你更深入地了解《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妈 6.0。大家好。大家好。
We have such a fun episode today, Lady. I'm really excited about it. We do. We are going to be discussing our favorite cold. opens. I think you guys have heard us use that term before. That's sort of like the two minutes of a TV show that precedes the title sequence. A lot of times on The Office, this was a standalone comedic bit that was separate from the plot of the episode, but sometimes it was on plot of the episode. Yeah. And we're going to get into some of our favorite cold opens with some special
我们今天有一集非常有趣的节目，辣妈。我对此感到非常兴奋。确实。我们将讨论我们最喜欢的开场白。我想你们以前听过我们用这个词。这有点像是电视剧中在片头曲之前的那两分钟。在《办公室》中，很多时候这是一个独立的喜剧桥段，与剧集的剧情无关，但有时它与剧集剧情有关。是的。今天我们将邀请一些特别的嘉宾，和我们一起探讨一些我们最喜欢的开场白。
guests today. We have Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, the host of How We Made Your Mother. We love their podcast. You guys know it. It's on our network. They rewatch each week an episode of How I Met Your Mother. And we're going to talk cold opens with them today. Yeah. We thought it would be kind of fun if we traded some of our favorite, the office cold opens, and they told us a couple of their favorites from How I Met Your Mother. But before we get to that, we have a really great chit chat. Yeah, this week's suggestion comes from Bailey M in Oklahoma City who said, hey ladies, Taylor Swift recently released a music video for her song, Opelite, and Donal Gleason is in it. It is glorious. She put a period after each word. Like it, like she wrote it out like, it is your birthday. But she put, it is glorious. Yes. Bailey said there's some Ned like dancing. Please discuss.
嘉宾今天，我们有《老爸老妈浪漫史》的主持人乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯。我们很喜欢他们的播客。大家也都知道。它在我们的网络上。他们每周重温一集《老爸老妈浪漫史》，今天我们将和他们聊聊开场白。是的。我们觉得，如果我们交换一些我们最喜欢的《办公室》开场白，而他们告诉我们他们最喜欢的《老爸老妈浪漫史》中的几个，那会挺有趣的。但在我们讨论那个之前，我们有一场非常棒的闲聊。是的，本周的建议来自俄克拉荷马城的贝利·M，她说，嘿，辣妈们，泰勒·斯威夫特最近为她的歌曲《Opelite》发布了一部音乐录影带，多纳尔·格里森也在里面。太棒了。她在每个词后面都加了一个句号。就像，就像她写出来的那样，就像，今天是你的生日。但她加了，太棒了。是的。贝利说有一些类似内德的舞蹈。请讨论一下。
Okay, Bailey. We were very curious about. all of this as well. And we did some digging. And this music video came about because Taylor and Donal were guests on the Graham Norton talk show, which is a really fun talk show. It's in England. There's like a big sofa and there's always a random assortment of celebrities on this sofa. And if you watch the episode of the talk show, you can literally see Taylor's eyes light up when she has the idea for this music video. It all started with Killian Murphy and Taylor. Siff complimenting Donal on his performance in the paper. Let's hear it.
好吧，贝利。我们对这一切也感到非常好奇。我们做了一些深入挖掘。这部音乐录影带的诞生是因为泰勒和多纳尔是格雷厄姆·诺顿脱口秀节目的嘉宾，这是一档非常有趣的脱口秀节目。它在英国。有一个大沙发，沙发上总是有各种各样的随机名人和他们坐在一起。如果你看那期脱口秀节目，你真的可以看到当泰勒萌生制作这部音乐录影带的想法时，她的眼睛都亮了。这一切都始于基里安·墨菲和泰勒·斯威夫特称赞多纳尔在《浴血黑帮》中的表演。让我们听听。
Donald is magnetic in that show. I love that show. I want to say to I'm so happy it's coming back, and his character is like the loveliest, most romanticizing character. He, like, romanticizes his life. And it's really sweet and beautiful. And also, I don't think that you just sound American, you seem American. I know.
多纳尔在该剧中极具吸引力。我喜欢那部剧。我想说，我太高兴它回归了，他的角色就像是那种最可爱、最浪漫化的角色。他，就像，浪漫化了他的生活。这真的很甜蜜、很美好。而且，我也觉得你不仅听起来像美国人，你看起来就像美国人。我知道。
So good. You have to leave that in the show. You have to be a skyrocket. Thank you, Taylor Swift. I'm very much. No, folks. You've got it up. Thank you.
太棒了。你必须把它留在节目里。你必须一飞冲天。谢谢你，泰勒·斯威夫特。我很荣幸。不，各位。你们成功了。谢谢。
But I also say it's just worth watching for Donald's dancing alone. Oh, my God. Yes, absolutely. Yeah. I'm hoping to get in the Taylor's music video. Yeah. I'm hoping. And as the music video came out,
但我还要说，光是看多纳尔的舞蹈就绝对值得一看。哦，天哪。是的，绝对的。是的。我希望能参演泰勒的音乐录影带。是的。我希望。随着音乐录影带的发布，
Graham Norton was a guest on a podcast called Wanging On, and he talks about all of it. Let's hear it. So tell us who was on your sofa that night. So basically, well, okay, I'll tell you what happened. So I got contacted by Taylor and Taylor's People, and they wanted to discuss, I think they wanted to discuss something.
格雷厄姆·诺顿是《Wanging On》播客的嘉宾，他在节目中谈到了这一切。我们来听听。那么告诉我们那天谁坐在你的沙发上。所以基本上，嗯，好吧，我来告诉你发生了什么。我被泰勒和泰勒团队联系了，他们想讨论，我想他们是想讨论某事。
I was like, oh, what that's about? And then something about the music video, and I thought, oh, what's that? And then I got through the thing, and it was like the whole thing came to her in a blinding flash on the sofa. Which you see in the video. If you stay to the end of the video, you see her get the idea. And it was, so she was on the show,
我当时想，哦，那是什么？然后是关于音乐录影带的事情，我想，哦，那是什么？然后我看了那件事，就像整个事情在沙发上如闪电般闪现在她的脑海里。你在视频中可以看到这一点。如果你看到视频的最后，你会看到她想到了这个主意。当时是这样的，她上了节目，
with Killian Murphy, Donald Gleason, Greta Lee, Jodie, Jury Turner Smith, and Lewis Cabaldi. And Donald Gleason said something about his dancing, and he said, oh, I'm hoping to be in the next day of Swift video. And you see her little eyes go, but doing, little light bulb moment. And the next thing, you know, she's written this whole treatment, and we're all in it. And everyone was available.
和基里安·墨菲、多纳尔·格里森、格蕾塔·李、朱迪、茱莉·特纳·史密斯和刘易斯·卡帕尔迪一起。多纳尔·格里森说了一些关于他的舞蹈的话，他说，哦，我希望成为下一部泰勒·斯威夫特视频的主角。然后你看到她的小眼睛亮了一下，就像，灯泡亮了一下。接下来你知道的，她写了整个剧本，我们都在里面。每个人都有空。
Everyone agreed to do it. He also said that it was, quote, like shooting a movie. It was a massive, massive deal. And everyone was lovely on. on set. It was a really, really fun experience. And he said they filmed his scenes at the Witt Gift Shopping Center in South London towards the end of 2025. And he was so excited to finally be able to talk about it. Well, I mean, first of all, if Taylor Swift asked you to be in her music video, of course,
大家都同意参与。他还说，这，引用他的话说，“就像拍电影一样”。这是一件非常非常大的事。片场每个人都很可爱。这真的是一次非常非常有趣的经历。他说他们于 2025 年底在伦敦南部的威特吉夫购物中心拍摄了他的场景。他终于能够谈论这件事感到非常兴奋。嗯，我的意思是，首先，如果泰勒·斯威夫特邀请你参演她的音乐录影带，当然，
the answer is yes. Come on. Of course. I mean, anything, Taylor, of course. I mean, Taylor, if you need to you know, ladies of a certain season. Yes, we're there for you, Taylor. We're there for you, Taylor. Well, it's very funny because I have a little fun surprise to share. Also, about Taylor Swift, I was in our general mailbag for office ladies, and I found this letter from Kayla M in upstate New York. And Kayla, I thank you so much for this letter because I'm...
答案是肯定的。拜托。当然。我的意思是，任何事，泰勒，当然。我的意思是，泰勒，如果你需要，你知道，某个特定季节的辣妈。是的，我们为你而在，泰勒。我们为你而在，泰勒。嗯，这非常有趣，因为我有一个小小的惊喜要分享。同样关于泰勒·斯威夫特，我在“办公室辣妈”的通用邮箱里，发现了这封来自纽约州北部凯拉·M的信。凯拉，非常感谢你写这封信，因为我……
I didn't know this, and it was a very exciting moment for my family. Here is what Kayla said. Hi, office ladies, this is urgent. Did you know that Jenna can be seen in the Taylor Swift, the Erez Tour, the final show concert movie? I noticed and screamed. What? Yes, lady. Yes.
我以前不知道这件事，对于我的家来说，这是一个非常激动人心的时刻。凯拉是这么说的。嘿，办公室辣妈，这很紧急。你知道在泰勒·斯威夫特的《时代巡回演唱会：最终场演唱会电影》中可以看到珍娜吗？我注意到了，然后尖叫了。什么？是的，辣妈。是的。
Ah! So, Kayla says, just toward the end of all too well, during the Red era, you're in the crowd singing along and wearing your friendship bracelets. I cannot believe I just noticed this, considering how many times I have watched it. Love you, ladies. You are kidding me. We both went to Taylor's Eress Tour. I cannot believe I was not at the one in Vancouver.
啊！所以，凯拉说，就在《All Too Well》快结束时，在红发时代（Red era）期间，你在人群中跟着唱，还戴着你的友谊手链。考虑到我看了多少次，我简直不敢相信我刚刚才注意到这一点。爱你们，辣妈。你在开玩笑吧。我们俩都去了泰勒的时代巡回演唱会。我简直不敢相信我不在温哥华那场。
You were in Vancouver. I was in New Orleans. Lady, you made it into her movie? I can't believe it. I cannot believe it. My daughter and I went to that together. I took a screen grab of it. I was going to say, I need a screen grab immediately.
你在温哥华。我在新奥尔良。辣妈，你进她的电影里了？我真不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。我和我女儿一起去的。我截了屏。我正想说，我马上需要一张截屏。
It's a very fun moment because I am just looking up at the stage with just like stars in my eyes. I look really happy. I've got my friendship bracelets. And I was really happy. It was such a special night for me. So, lady, I took a screen grab of it. Here it is. Look at me.
这是一个非常有趣的时刻，因为我正抬头看着舞台，眼里闪烁着星星。我看起来真的很高兴。我戴着我的友谊手链。我当时真的很高兴。对我和说这真是一个特别的夜晚。所以，辣妈，我截了张图。给你看。看我。
I've got, I'm holding my hands up under my chin. I'm looking up. I'm smiling. Oh my gosh, I see you. I've got my light up bracelet on. Yes. Oh, that is so special. That is so fun. And you know, right to my left there is my daughter, who didn't make it into the movie, but who was there that night, and it was just such a special night for us. And yeah, but isn't that crazy? That is crazy, crazy. Okay, so I also went with my daughter, but Jenna, What did you wear? Because I look back at my pictures. I wore like sparkly cat ears and I had glitter on my face. Like what did you wear? So I wore, remember that sparkly sequin jacket that I got from Macy's? Yes. Yeah. So I wore just black pants and a t-shirt and then I wore that sparkly jacket because I was deep in hot slash mode at that point and I knew I was going to be taking my jacket. on and off. Yeah, you went sparkly jacket. I bought a shirt that said karma is a cat, and I wore
我有，我双手托着下巴。我抬头看着。我在笑。哦天哪，我看到你了。我戴着发光手链。是的。哦，太特别了。太有趣了。你知道，就在我的左边是我的女儿，她没有进入电影，但她那天晚上也在那里，对我们来说这真是一个如此特别的夜晚。是的，但这不是很疯狂吗？太疯狂了，太疯狂了。好吧，所以我也和我女儿一起去了，但是珍娜，你穿了什么？因为我回看我的照片。我戴着亮闪闪的猫耳朵，脸上还有亮片。你穿了什么？所以，我穿了，还记得我从梅西百货买的那件闪亮的亮片夹克吗？是的。是的。所以我穿了黑裤子和T恤，然后穿了那件闪亮的夹克，因为当时我深陷“热门”模式，我知道我要脱下夹克。进进出出。是的，你穿了闪亮的夹克。我买了一件写着“报应是一只猫”的衬衫，我戴着
cat ears. But what a glorious, wonderful, joyful experience that was, and I cannot believe you're in the dang movie. That is so cool. Taylor our offer still stands. I know Jenna's been in the movie, but if you need us to be in any future music videos, literally any future anything. And actually anything, right? We're here for you. Well, thank you. so much to Bailey for writing in with that chit-chat. I had a lot of fun watching all of those clips. We're going to take a short break, and when we come back, we're going to discuss cold opens with Craig and Josh. Hello, there, fine gentlemen. Why, hello? Oh, is that us? We're the fine gentlemen. We're the fine gentlemen. I was so confused. You are the fine gentlemen.
猫耳朵。但那是一次多么光荣、美好、快乐的经历，我简直不敢相信你竟然出现在那部该死的电影里。太酷了。泰勒，我们的提议依然有效。我知道珍娜已经拍了电影，但如果你需要我们出现在任何未来的音乐录影带中，字面上的任何未来的一切。事实上任何事，对吧？我们为你在这里。嗯，非常感谢贝利写信分享那段闲聊。看所有这些剪辑我玩得很开心。我们要休息一小会儿，回来后，我们将与克雷格和乔什讨论开场白。你们好，优秀的绅士们。哎呀，你好？哦，那是我们吗？我们是优秀的绅士。我们是优秀的绅士。我太困惑了。你们是优秀的绅士。
My goodness, of course. It's so great to be chatting with you again. We love chatting with you guys. Thanks for having us back. Yes, fine gentlemen. It's lovely to see you. Talk of the morning to you. Well, we're really excited to chat cold opens with you. And Craig, it's really cool to have you on the podcast today because you're going to give us a little bit of, I hope, a writer, showrunner's perspective on the cold open. Could you tell our audience, what is a cold open? No pressure, by the way, no pressure. Yeah, I know. I have to define the entire genre of cold open. And this will be canon, whatever you say. This will go right in the dictionary. It's a little. little funny thing at the start of the show. That's the really short version. I think the office was amazing at doing ones that were these little self-contained movies, these little mini short films that kind of that stood alone sometimes. They didn't always kick off the story. Am I right,
天哪，当然。很高兴能再次和你们聊天。我们喜欢和你们聊天。谢谢你们邀请我们回来。是的，优秀的绅士。很高兴见到你们。祝你们早上好。嗯，我们真的很高兴和你们聊聊开场白。克雷格，很高兴今天你能来到播客，因为你将给我们，我希望，从一个编剧、运作人的角度来谈谈开场白。你能告诉我们的观众，什么是开场白吗？顺便说一句，没有压力，没有压力。是的，我知道。我得定义开场白的整个流派。无论你说什么，都将成为经典。这可以直接写进字典里。这是一个小小的。节目开始时的小笑料。这就是极简版本。我认为《办公室》在制作这些独立的微电影、这些有时可以独立的迷你短片方面非常出色。它们并不总是开启故事。我说的对吗，
you guys? It feels like that was often true for you guys. That's so hard to do that we almost never did it on how I met your mother. We were too lazy. We're like, it's too hard to make a little like gem. So we often, we usually started the story off somehow in our cold opens. You can either kick off the plot in the cold open. You can either kick off the plot in the cold or it's just a funny little thing. And those are sort of the two ways to go. We sometimes did the funny little thing version on how much your mother, but usually we try to get the story started in some way.
你们？感觉这经常适用于你们。这太难做到了，以至于我们在《老爸老妈浪漫史》中几乎从不这样做。我们太懒了。我们觉得，制作一个小小的宝石太难了。所以我们经常，我们的开场白通常会以某种方式开始故事。你可以在开场白中拉开剧情的序幕。你可以在开场白中拉开剧情的序幕，或者它只是一个小笑料。这基本上是这两种方式。我们在《老爸老妈浪漫史》中有时会采用小笑料的版本，但通常我们会试图以某种方式开始故事。
I would argue that doing the funny standalone way is probably harder because when you're starting the story, at least has some momentum. But you guys did it ingeniously on the office. Well, you know, we all today picked one of our favorite cold opens from each of our shows. We're going to share those. We'll set them up and we'll talk about them. And I know the one I picked, I'm not going to say it yet,
我认为制作幽默的独立方式可能更难，因为当你开始讲故事时，至少有一些势头。但你们在《办公室》里巧妙地做到了这一点。好吧，你知道，我们今天都从各自的节目中挑选了一个最喜欢的开场白。我们会分享这些。我们会做好铺垫并讨论它们。我知道我选的那一个，我先不说，
but I almost picked the episode, The Injury, and that was a time we had a cold open on the office that did kick off the episode. That's when Michael has a George Foreman grill by his bed because he loves the fresh bacon in the morning and he steps on the grill. But so that cold open where he calls Pam in a panic is one that then leads into the whole episode. So we did that every once in a while, but you're right. Mostly ours were these standalone little movies. Did you guys tell us in one of the episodes we did together that, Often they would write it for one and it would end up on another episode. Like they would mix and match them.
但我差点选了《工伤》那一集，那是《办公室》中开场白真正拉开剧集序幕的一次。那是迈克尔的床边放着一个乔治·福尔曼烤架，因为他喜欢早上吃新鲜的培根，结果他踩到了烤架上。所以迈克尔惊慌失措地打电话给帕姆的那个开场白，随后引发了整集的故事。所以我们偶尔会那样做，但你说得对。大部分我们的开场白都是这些独立的微电影。你们在我们在的一集里告诉过我们，通常他们会为一个写，结果却最终出现在另一集里。就像他们会把它们混合搭配一样。
They were always the ones that you thought they were going to be paired with. Yeah, exactly. Because they were movable because they were their own little story. But also, sometimes they just got rid of them completely because they needed the time to tell the story of the episode. Right. And if it is self-contained and modular like that, it's easier to take out. Whereas if you start the story, you're kind of stuck with it. Did you guys always do a cold open?
它们总是那些你以为会被配在一起的。是的，没错。因为它们是可以移动的，因为它们是它们自己的小故事。而且，有时它们甚至被完全删掉了，因为他们需要时间来讲述剧集的故事。没错。如果它是独立且模块化的，就更容易拿掉。而如果你开始讲故事，你就有点被套牢了。你们总是做开场白吗？
because we didn't do it every episode. We did sort of longer, like, full act ones. We started the show with titles for the entire first season and then kind of mixed and matched, although we realized, like, in season two, that we had a great theme song to smash cut to. Yeah. Do you know what I mean?
因为我们不是每集都做。我们做了更长的、像第一幕完整的戏。我们在整个第一季开始时都有片名字幕，然后进行了混合搭配，尽管我们意识到，比如在第二季，我们有一个很棒的主题曲可以卡点转场。是的。你知道我的意思吗？
With that, like, hard cut to the, dun, dent, dent, da, da, da, da, da. It's like, it's perfect for that. How are we not? We were like, why are we doing this? I was going to say, though, both our shows have really iconic, grab you by the lapels kind of theme songs.
伴随着那种强烈的剪辑到，登，登，登，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒。就像，这太完美了。我们怎么能不呢？我们当时想，我们为什么要在这样做？不过我想说，我们的两部剧都有非常标志性的、能一下子抓住你注意力的主题曲。
Yeah. And there's something especially about if you do the first season, people get to know the theme song. By the second season, it's actually really thrilling to do a cold open and then cut, you know, do the needle drop to the theme song. Yeah, I feel like our theme songs were almost the button at the end of the scene sometimes, right? Yeah. You know, Craig, we did usually have a cold open. Every once in a while, we wouldn't for time, but for the most part, we did. And I think about our writer's room and how much fun they had coming up with these standalone cold open ideas. I mean, Kevin's chilly.
是的。而且特别有意思的是，如果你制作第一季，人们会了解主题曲。到第二季时，做一个开场白然后剪辑，你知道的，把主题曲作为音乐转场，其实非常令人兴奋。是的，我觉得我们的主题曲有时几乎成了场景结束时的点睛之笔，对吧？是的。你知道，克雷格，我们通常确实有开场白。偶尔为了赶时间我们不会有，但大部分时间我们都有。我想起我们的编剧室，他们在想出这些独立的开场白创意时玩得多么开心。我是说，凯文的辣椒。
My lord. Yeah. That one, that was Aaron Scher. And I just, people quote that to Brian. I think for the rest of his life, he's going to hear that. I think also it's a great way if you have a card on the wall that's a funny idea, but you just can't make it a whole episode, but you could make it a really funny two minutes. I think a lot of our cold opens were things also that might be feeling a little too absurd
天哪。是的，那是亚伦·舍尔。我只是，人们对布莱恩引用那句话。我想在他余生的时间里，他都会听到这句话。我也认为这是一种好方法，如果你墙上有一张卡片是一个有趣的主意，但你就是无法把它拍成完整的一集，但你可以把它拍成一个非常有趣的头两分钟。我认为我们的很多开场白也是一些对于我们正在拍摄的纪录片小节目来说可能感觉有点太荒谬的想法，
for our little documentary show that we were putting on. but we could be a little more broad in our cold opens as well, which brings us to, speaking of a little bit of a broader cold open, Angela, your pick. It's one of our classics. So I wanted to pick a cold open that was a real all-ensemble moment because sometimes the cold opens were mostly, you know, Michael or Dwight and those kind of storylines.
但我们在开场白中可以更广泛一些，这让我们想到了，说到更广泛一点的开场白，安吉拉，你的选择。这是我们的经典之作之一。所以我想要选一个真正全员出动的开场白，因为有时开场白主要都是，你知道的，迈克尔或德怀特和那些类型的剧情。
But this had everybody. It included a huge rehearsal with our camera operators, our boom operators. It was like a real dance, if you will. it's something I get yelled at the airport, okay? So basically, this is from stress relief, the episode's stress relief. It is that famous fire drill cold open where Dwight is going to teach everyone how to survive an office place fire. By setting a fire. Yes, by locking the doors and setting a fire. It's absolute instant
但这包含了所有人。它包括与我们的摄影师、麦克风收音师的大型彩排。这就像是一支真正的舞蹈，如果你愿意这么说的话。这是我在机场会被人冲着大喊的桥段，好吧？所以基本上，这来自《减压》，那一集叫《减压》。这就是那个著名的消防演习开场白，德怀特要教大家如何在办公室火灾中生存。通过放火。是的，通过锁上门并放火。这是一场绝对即时的
mayhem. We pulled a clip from the middle where Dwight is trying to get everyone to do all the steps in the chaos. Here it is. Have you ever seen a burn victim? Okay. Procedure, procedure. Exit options. Where do we go, folks? Use a what to cover the mouth?
混乱。我们截取了中间的一个片段，在混乱中德怀特正试图让每个人都按照步骤做。给你。你见过烧伤病人吗？好的。程序，程序。疏散选择。我们去哪儿，伙计们？用什么来遮住嘴？
A what? A rag, a damp rag, perhaps. Let's remember those procedures. What are the options? That's the wrong way. We've already tried that. Remember your exit points. Exit points, people.
什么？一块抹布，也许是一块湿抹布。让我们记住这些程序。选择有哪些？那条路走错了。我们已经试过了。记住你的疏散点。疏散点，各位。
What's next? Oscar! Stay alive. I'm getting help. Pull me up. You're too heavy. I only weigh 82 pounds. Say Bandit. One, 911.
接下来的剧情是什么？奥斯卡！坚持住。我在叫人帮忙。把我拉上去。你太重了。我只有82磅。说“班迪特”。一，911。
Oh, my God. It's so ridiculous. It's so great. Can I ask a question? How long did that take to shoot that? That looks like an entire movie. Well, it was a full day to shoot it, but it was also a bunch of rehearsal. Yeah.
哦，天哪。太荒谬了。太棒了。我能问个问题吗？拍那个镜头花了多长时间？那看起来像是一整部电影。嗯，拍了一整天，但也排练了很多次。对。
I came in a day early, and I had to work with this cat and the cat wrangler, and we had a fake cat. We had a real cat and a fake cat, and I had a body double. Like that stunt, just that moment of throwing the cat in the ceiling and it coming out the other side was a huge stunt. I just love like the unexpected. Like the first throw of the cat is hilarious and unexpected. But so soon after is that second falling cat, which you're not quite expecting, which is like the actual enormous laugh of that moment. And the cat was totally okay. Everyone listening, our line producer had put a whole bunch of like ferny pad things.
我提前一天就去了，我必须和这只猫以及驯猫师合作，我们有一只假猫。我们有一只真猫和一只假猫，我还有一个替身演员。就像那个特技一样，仅仅是把猫扔进天花板然后它从另一边掉出来的那个瞬间就是一个巨大的特技。我就是喜欢这种意料之外的事情。就像第一次把猫扔出去，既搞笑又出人意料。但紧接着就是第二次猫下落的场景，这是你完全没料到的，这可以说是那一刻真正巨大的笑点。而且那猫完全没事。听节目的各位，我们的执行制片人铺了厚厚一层像蕨类垫子一样的东西。
So he did hit something squishy and soft. I love also, though, Rain's unflappable kind of commitment to, like, and everyone is absolutely panicking around him. I heard Adam McKay say this thing, that there's nothing funnier than people being confidently wrong. And so much of Dwight is confident wrongness. And so much of, like, the humor on the office is confident, absolute wrongness. Well, that's definitely Michael Scott.
所以它的确摔在了一个又软又有弹性的东西上。不过，我也很喜欢雷恩那种泰然自若的坚持，而他周围每个人都在彻底惊慌失措。我听亚当·麦凯说过这样的话，世上没有什么比人们自信满满地犯错更搞笑的事情了。而德怀特身上有很大一部分特质就是充满自信的错误。办公室里的很多幽默也正是这种绝对自信的、彻头彻尾的错误。嗯，那绝对是迈克尔·斯科特。
He's like the most confident idiot. ever. There's something about us. We love it. We love that confident wrongness. Yeah. All right. So we asked you guys to pull your favorite cold opens. And I know there's, it's always so hard to pick one. But Josh, which one did you pick? So I picked an episode from season four. It's called Right Place, Right Time. I think it was episode 22 from season four. It kind of starts off in a little bit of a minor key in terms of, you know, Robin and Ted and this morning scene. And he's running out to, he's going to go get a bagel, like a very kind of low-key New York morning. And then he goes out the front door and he's about to turn one way, but he stops and he turns another way. He goes another direction.
他简直是个史上最自信的笨蛋。我们身上就是有某种特质。我们太喜欢了。我们就是喜欢那种自信满满的错误。好啦。所以我们让你们选出自己最喜欢的冷开场。我知道，选出一个总是很难。但是乔希，你选了哪一个？我选了第四季的一集。它叫“对的时间，对的地点”。我想那是第四季的第22集。它以一种稍微有点低沉的基调开场，关于罗宾、泰德以及这个早晨的场景。他急匆匆地跑出去，打算去买个百吉饼，就像一个非常低调的纽约早晨。然后他走出了前门，正要往一个方向拐，但他停了下来，又转向了另一个方向。他朝另一个方向走去。
And then the narrator comes in and starts talking about, you know, almost the butterfly effect, essentially, like our seemingly innocuous choices are all kind of adding up together in this magical way to deliver us where we need to be. And also, right when he leaves, he grabs the yellow umbrella, which at that point we had established as an iconic prop. Yeah, we told the audience that is involved in how Ted is going to meet the mother eventually. That's like this magical little flash forward we saw a yellow umbrella as part of that meeting. Right. So he's like, he's just going outside to get a bagel, but he grabs this yellow umbrella. And then it's, oh my God, like now this is very, very significant.
然后旁白进场，开始谈论，基本上差不多就是蝴蝶效应，也就是我们那些看似微不足道的选择，正以一种神奇的方式汇聚在一起，把我们带到我们该去的地方。而且，就在他离开的时候，他抓起了那把黄色雨伞，当时我们已经把它打造成了一个标志性的道具。对，我们告诉观众，这把伞关乎泰德最终将如何遇见孩子们的母亲。这就像是一个神奇的小闪回，我们在那次相遇中看到了黄色雨伞作为其中的一部分。对。所以他就像是，他只是去外面买个百吉饼，但他顺手拿了这把黄色雨伞。然后，哦，天哪，现在这变得非常非常重要了。
And then it starts to rain and he opens the umbrella. And then he gets a tap on his shoulder and he turns and we don't know who he's seeing. But the fake out, of course, is this must be the mother. Right. And that's when you cut to main titles and you don't see the face. You have to watch the whole episode to see who's behind that umbrella. I loved this cold open. And I also love the voiceover, which is by Bob Saget. So I would love to hear that because it's poetic and wonderful and I love it. Kids, I've been telling you the story of how I met your mother. And while there's many things to learn from this story, this may be the biggest. The great moments of your life won't necessarily be the things you do. They'll also be the things that happened to you. Now I'm not saying you can't take action to affect the outcome of your life. You have to take action, and you will.
接着开始下雨了，他撑开了雨伞。然后有人拍了一下他的肩膀，他转过身去，我们不知道他看到了谁。但这个障眼法，当然了，这肯定就是母亲了。对。就在这时画面切到了片头，你没有看到那张脸。你必须看完整集才能知道那把伞后面到底是谁。我太喜欢这个冷开场了。我也很喜欢由鲍勃·萨吉特配音的旁白。所以我很想听听那段，因为它是那么富有诗意、那么美妙，我爱死它了。孩子们，我一直在给你们讲我是怎么遇到你们母亲的故事。虽然从这个故事中可以学到很多东西，但这或许是最重要的一课。你生命中的伟大时刻不一定是你所做的事情。它们也将是发生在你身上的事情。现在我不是说你不能采取行动来影响你的人生结局。你必须采取行动，而且你也会这么做的。
But never forget that on any day you can step out the front door and your whole life can change forever. You see, the universe has a plan, kids, and that plan is always in motion. A butterfly flaps its wings, and it starts to rain. It's a scary thought, but it's also kind of wonderful. All these little parts of the machine constantly working, making sure that you end up exactly where you're supposed to be, exactly when you're supposed to be there. The right place at the right time.
但永远不要忘记，在任何一天，你走出前门，你的整个人生都可能永远改变。你看，宇宙有一个计划，孩子们，而这个计划一直在运转。一只蝴蝶扇动翅膀，然后就开始下雨了。这是一个可怕的想法，但它也相当美妙。机器的所有这些小部件都在不断运转，确保你最终准确无误地到达你该去的地方，就在你该去的那一刻。在对的时间，在对的地点。
Oh, there is so beautiful. Craig, I think that's some of the most, like, kind of lyrical narrating, writing that you and the gang did. And I also, it really strikes me that the entire DNA, like blueprint of the entire series is in that cold open. Yeah. Right? Yeah.
哦，真是太美了。克雷格，我觉得那是你和伙伴们写过的最具抒情色彩的旁白和台词之一。而且我真的觉得，整个系列的全部DNA，也就是蓝图，都包含在那个冷开场里了。对吧？对。
Yeah. It is. The whole show is spelled out thematically and illustrated in that. And then as the episode goes on, again, we talk about a lot about how I made your mother. One, it's a big mystery. It's a nine-season mystery. But also, a lot of episodes start off with something very strange and disorienting and what is going on. And then the episode solves the mystery.
对。就是这样。整部剧的主题都在其中阐述并得到了生动的展现。随着剧集的推进，我们再次谈到了很多关于《老爸老妈浪漫史》的内容。第一，这是一个巨大的谜团。这是一个历时九季的谜团。但同时，很多剧集都是以某种非常奇怪、令人摸不着头脑、不知道发生了什么的情况开场的。然后剧集会解开这个谜团。
So it's like a mysteries inside mysteries inside mysteries. Yeah. And this is like, this is a great mystery episode, but it's also, it just lays out all the themes. so beautifully at the beginning. And Bob, man, I love hearing Bob's voice. I know. I get such a chill note, hearing Bob do that one. He was such a secret weapon of the show.
所以这就像是谜中之谜中之谜。对。这就像是，这是一个极棒的悬疑剧集，但它同时也在开头非常优美地铺陈了所有的主题。而且鲍勃，天哪，我太喜欢听鲍勃的声音了。我知道。听到鲍勃说那段台词，我起了一身鸡皮疙瘩。他是这部剧里的一张秘密王牌。
He was so good at being Future Ted telling his kids that story. And I think it's an underrated kind of like track in the overall song of our show. You know, that's like a really crucial instrument in the orchestra there. And he was wonderful. It makes me miss him. He was just a great guy. And he loved playing that part. He took a lot of pride in being future.
他太擅长扮演向孩子们讲述那个故事的年老泰德了。我觉得在我们整部剧的“交响乐”中，这是一个被低估的“音轨”。你知道的，那就像是管弦乐队里非常关键的一件乐器。而且他太棒了。这让我很想念他。他真是一个大好人。他非常喜欢扮演那个角色。他为扮演年老泰德感到无比自豪。
Ted. He and Josh developed a real bond because he's like, I'm future you. I'm the voice of future. And you guys like really became close over that. And you hear it. He would watch the episode. He'd tap into where Ted was emotionally. And he'd perform that. And I love that about him. And yeah, this is kind of the whole series and miniature. Since this whole episode that you're having us on is a symposium on cold opens. This is another way we used cold opens, which is we liked teasing a mystery. We liked really getting right up to a mystery moment, hard cutting the credits. and you have to stay tuned for the next 20 minutes to find out, in this case, who's behind that umbrella.
他和乔希建立了一种真正的羁绊，因为他说：“我是年老的你。我是年老者的声音。”你们俩真的因为这个变得非常亲密。你能听出来。他会看剧集。他能捕捉到泰德当时的内心情感。然后他会把那种情绪表演出来。我太喜欢他这一点了。是的，这就好比整个系列的微缩版。既然你们今天邀请我们来，就像是在办一场关于冷开场的研讨会。这是我们使用冷开场的另一种方式，也就是我们喜欢设置一个悬念。我们喜欢把剧情推向悬念发生的瞬间，然后立刻切到片花，而你必须在接下来的20分钟里保持关注，才能在这一次的情况下，找出那把伞后面到底是谁。
It turns out to be Meryl Streep playing herself. But you need to watch the rest of the episode. And that's what I mean by we usually put the cold open on how I met your mother was like a load-bearing support of the architecture because we really start the story there. We plant a mystery or we kick something off in some way. We didn't do as many free standards as you guys did, which again are really hard to do. One other thing I want to say about that cold open, again, You know, when Craig and I've been doing how we made your mother, part of it is like the mystery of why people love the show so much and why do people still want to talk about them and play them for their kids and all this stuff.
结果发现是梅丽尔·斯特里普在扮演她自己。但你需要看完整集。这就是我的意思，我们通常把《老爸老妈浪漫史》的冷开场当作架构的承重支柱，因为我们确实是从那里开始铺陈故事的。我们埋下一个悬念，或者以某种方式拉开序幕。我们不像你们那样做那么多随性的脱口秀式开场，这再次说明它们真的很难拍。关于那个冷开场，我还想说一件事，再次说明，你知道的，当我和克雷格一直在制作《老爸老妈浪漫史》时，其中一部分就像是一个谜：为什么人们那么喜欢这部剧？为什么人们仍然想谈论它、放给孩子们看以及所有这些事情？
And one of the things that I think people find so much solace in is that it's a meaningful universe. How I met your mother says the universe, both in this show and presumably the one that you're existing in also is meaningful. And every little encounter has meaning. And it's kind of an antidote to cynicism. It's an antidote to nihilism, you know, or chaos. That there's a plan and there's benevolence and there's a guiding hand. And I think that even if people don't articulate it that way, that's part of the warmth they feel when they watch the show and why they keep coming back to it. I so agree.
我认为人们能在其中获得极大的慰藉的原因之一，就是它是一个有意义的宇宙。《老爸老妈浪漫史》表明，这个宇宙——无论是在这部剧中，还是大概也就是你现在身处的这个宇宙——都是有意义的。每一个微小的相遇都有意义。这可以说是对愤世嫉俗的一种解药。你知道的，这是对虚无主义或混乱的一种解药。那就是有一个计划，有善意，还有一只引导之手。我认为，即使人们没有那样明确地表达出来，这也是他们看这部剧时感受到的温暖的一部分，也是他们不断回看它的原因。我太赞同了。
It's like comfort, you know, when I watch your show, it makes me feel like everything's okay in some way. And I want you guys to know just yesterday I met a woman who told me she loves your podcast. She's an office ladies listener. She's so excited. It's on our network. And then she told me that her and her husband recreated the moment with the umbrella, with the trench coat, where you only see the legs, you know? And she pulled out her phone and showed it to me. And then I was like, I'm actually seeing them tomorrow and we're watching this cold open.
这就像是一种抚慰，你知道的，当我看你们的剧时，它在某种程度上让我觉得一切都很好。我想让你们知道，就在昨天，我遇到了一位女士，她告诉我她很喜欢你们的播客。她是《办公室女士》的听众。她超级兴奋。它就在我们的网络平台上。然后她告诉我，她和她丈夫用雨衣、雨伞重新演绎了那个场景，就是只能看到双腿的那种，你知道吗？然后她掏出手机给我看。接着我说：“我明天其实就要见到他们了，我们正在看这个冷开场。”
So I just think that your show is really meaningful to people. And that's a special thing. We need those touchstones. I think we're two for two. We're hitting them out of the park. And so, okay, who's up next? Jenna, it's you. Sure.
所以我只是觉得你们的节目对人们来说真的很有意义。这是一件很特别的事。我们需要这些精神支柱。我觉得我们两战全胜。我们把它们打出了本垒打。那么，好吧，接下来该谁了？珍娜，轮到你了。当然。
Well, I felt a little shy about picking this one because I am the star of it, but I only ever got to star in one cold open. And it is one of my favorites. It was in season nine. And it also features the whole ensemble because those were also my favorite cold opens. You know, a lot of our cold opens were a great opportunity for Jim to play a prank on Dwight. Those are some of our most famous ones, you know, Bears Beats,
嗯，对于选这个片段我感到有点害羞，因为我是里面的明星，但我一生中只在一部冷开场里当过主角。而且它也是我最喜欢的之一。它在第九季。它还汇集了全体演员阵容，因为那些也是我最喜欢的冷开场。你知道的，我们的很多冷开场都是吉姆捉弄德怀特的大好机会。那些是我们最著名的桥段，你知道的，熊、超越、
Star Galactica, when he puts his desk in the bathroom, or it features Michael doing something crazy like parkour or needing to put his face in cement. So this one was really fun for me. It's Pam's chore wheel, and it's near and dear to my heart. If there was one prop that I wish I had from the show, it would have been any of these chore wheels. I wish I had that hanging in my office. But basically what happens in this is the office is really dirty. It's messy. I mean, you even see like a little rat crawl across the floor. And Pam's the office administrator, and she has to try to come up with some sort of cleaning schedule
星际大战，当他把办公桌搬进洗手间时，或者是迈克尔做一些疯狂的事情，比如跑酷或者需要把脸埋进水泥里。所以这个片段对我和来说真的很有趣。这是帕姆的家务轮盘，它在我心中有着特殊的地位。如果说有什么道具我希望能够从剧里带走的话，那就是这些家务轮盘中的任何一个。我希望我的办公室里也挂着这个。但这里面发生的事情基本上就是办公室真的很脏。很凌乱。我的意思是，你甚至能看到一只小老鼠在地板上爬过。而帕姆是办公室管理员，她必须设法想出某种清洁时间表，
where people divide up all of the chores. So she tries making a chore wheel. We have a little clip from the top of this one. We can take a listen. The building's custodian is on vacation for the month, and Dwight is too cheap to hire a replacement. So instead, we're living in filth, but not for long, because I have created the chore wheel.
让大家来分担所有的家务。所以她尝试制作了一个家务轮盘。我们有这个片段开头的剪辑。我们可以听一下。大楼的管理员这整整一个月都在休假，而德怀特又太抠门不肯请人来顶替。所以结果就是，我们生活在垃圾堆里，不过好日子不会太久了，因为我制作了家务轮盘。
Oh yeah. Can I spin first? Well, it doesn't spin. We'll just move the wheel one notch each morning, and you see what chore you get that day. A wheel is supposed to spin. Yeah. You know, like, go-g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g. No, I'm familiar with spinning.
哦，耶。我能先转吗？嗯，它不转。我们每天早上只需把转盘拨一个格，你就能看到那天你分到什么家务。转盘不就应该是用来转的吗？对。你知道的，就像，g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g-g。不，我知道怎么转。
It's just that wouldn't work with a chore wheel because people might get the same chore. Buh, boring. All she talks about is chores. A wheel wants to spin, Pam. Spinning would be more fun. Okay, that's what I'm talking about. Big money, big money.
只是用家务轮盘的话这样行不通，因为大家可能会抽到同样的家务。啊，太无聊了。她满嘴都是家务。轮盘就该转起来，帕姆。转起来才更好玩。好啦，这正合我意。大奖，大奖。
So she makes a spinning wheel, and then they get mad because the only thing that you can win is a chore. So then she has to make another wheel where you win fun stuff, but there's one thing on the wheel that's called tiny wheel. And if you hit tiny wheel, you have to spin a tinier chore wheel that's really cute. And that has actual chores on it. But Pam says, no one cares. because the tiny wheel is so cute. And it was just funny and, you know, silly and I don't know. I would love a chore wheel in real life.
所以她制作了一个旋转轮盘，然后他们生气了，因为你唯一能赢得的东西就是家务。于是她不得不制作另一个轮盘，在上面你可以赢得好玩的东西，但轮盘上有一项叫做“迷你轮盘”。如果你转中了迷你轮盘，你就必须去转一个更小、非常可爱的迷你家务轮盘。上面有真正的家务。但帕姆说，没人会在意。因为迷你轮盘实在是太可爱了。这真的很有趣，而且你知道的，很滑稽，我不知道。我真希望现实生活中也能有一个家务轮盘。
I was going to say, Jenna, I don't know you that well yet. But this seems to me like entirely door-to-door something you would do. Am I right about that? Yes, bingo. I think it's another reason why she loves it is because in real life, Jenna, you do make a chore list. I love her a go, Jenna. I'm a Pisces. I'm a very organized Pisces.
我本想说，珍娜，我还不是很了解你。但这在我看来完全是你会做的事。我猜得对吗？没错，完全正确。我想这也是她喜欢它的另一个原因，因为在现实生活中，珍娜，你确实会列家务清单。我喜欢她的这种干劲，珍娜。我是双鱼座。我是一个非常有条理的双鱼座。
The tiny wheel feels very you. I feel like you would definitely do the tiny wheel part. We're going to make this fun. We got a tiny wheel. Yeah, it's super tiny. And I think it just also, it's like having kids and trying to get them excited about chores. Like, there's all these adults in the room, but they're just acting like children. And she's having to like manipulate them into keeping their own space clean.
迷你轮盘感觉太符合你的风格了。我觉得你绝对会做迷你轮盘那一部分。我们要把它变得有趣。我们有个迷你轮盘。对，它超小的。而且我觉得这也意味着，这就像生了孩子然后试图让他们对家务兴奋起来一样。房间里有这么多的成年人，但他们表现得就像小孩子一样。而她不得不像哄小孩一样操纵他们去保持自己空间的清洁。
It's like, don't you want it to be clean, guys? It's also fun to play as an actor when it's like you, again. everyone else. How everyone unites as like a single hive mind where they're like, no, it should spin, like a circle should spin, a wheel should spin. Yeah. Even Jim doesn't have her bad. Even Jim turns on you.
这就像是，难道你们不希望这里变干净吗，伙计们？作为一个演员，当你面对这种情况时，表演起来也很有趣，那就是你对抗所有人。每个人如何像一个单一的集体潜意识一样团结起来，他们会说：“不，它应该转，就像圆圈应该转一样，轮盘应该转。”对。甚至连吉姆都不站在她那边。甚至连吉姆也倒戈了。
But it's a little like I always like Simpsons crowd scenes are so funny when everyone like picks up like pitchforks and lanterns and just like Storm City Hall or whatever. So quickly over the over anything. And kind of shows like our ability to fall into like mass psychosis as a society. I loved as part of the ensemble whenever we would all collectively, like, react to one character. I loved it so much. I mean, Pam rarely had to hold everyone's attention in the conference room. That was normally Michael, right, all the time.
但这有点像——我一直觉得《辛普森一家》里那种乌合之众的场景太搞笑了，当每个人都拿起草叉和提灯，然后不管因为什么小事就去冲砸市政厅什么的。那种情绪转变得太快了。这也某种程度上展现了我们作为一个社会陷入群体性精神错乱的能力。我超喜欢作为群演的一部分，每当我们所有人集体对某一个角色做出反应的时候。我太喜欢了。我的意思是，帕姆很少需要在会议室里吸引所有人的注意力。通常那都是迈克尔，对吧，一直都是。
But it was so fun to just be like being the crowd and be like, we don't get it. I don't get it. Do you get it? I don't get it. It was super fun. I remember it was very intimidating to stand in front of you all, too. I was standing there and I was like, oh, my gosh, Steve did this for seven years. How did he do this?
但扮演人群中的一员并表现得像——我们不懂。我不懂。你懂吗？我不懂。这真的超级有趣。我记得站在你们所有人面前也让人感到非常畏惧。我站在那里心想：“哦，天哪，史蒂夫连续七年都是这么过来的。他是怎么做到的？”
But don't you feel like that's how Pam would feel? Like that feels very usable, like where an actor thing and character thing are probably close. Yes, like she has like this really great idea that she feels really confident about, but also as soon as anybody pushes back against her, she's like, oh no. Craig, I think it's your turn. You're the person who hasn't shared yet. I'm very nervous. Now, the funny thing is this is by far the simplest.
但你不觉得这就是帕姆当时的感受吗？感觉这非常实用，演员本人的状态和角色的状态可能很契合。是的，就好像她有一个自我感觉非常棒的好主意，但同时只要任何人对她提出反驳，她就会想：“噢，不。”克雷格，我觉得轮到你了。你是那个还没分享的人。我非常紧张。现在，有趣的是，这是我们今天讨论的所有片段中，到目前为止最简单的一个。
one of any of the ones that we talked about today. I chose it mainly because I'm looking at it through the lens of doing our podcast, of doing a rewatch podcast, where you go back and you investigate what the hell you did if you can remember it. And the way I felt about this cold open at the time was I really liked it, and I'll tell you why. And then we got up to this episode just a couple months ago, and we had the writer of this episode, Greg Malins, who worked on friends and how I met your mother. And he came on and he dropped a couple of bombs on me that made me completely change how I see this cold open now. So I chose mine to be podcast relevant. I'll set it up really quick because I think we're going to play a clip and then we're going to
我选择它主要是因为我是通过制作我们的播客、制作重温播客的视角来看待它的，在播客中，你要回顾并调查你到底干了些什么——如果你还记得的话。当时我对这个冷开场的感受是，我真的很喜欢它，原因我一会儿告诉你们。然后就在几个月前，我们播到了这一集，我们请来了这一集的编剧格雷格·马林斯，他曾在《老友记》和《老爸老妈浪漫史》工作过。他上我们的节目时，向我投下了几颗“重磅炸弹”，彻底改变了我现在对这个冷开场的看法。所以我选择我的片段是为了让它和播客相关。我先简单铺垫一下，因为我觉得我们要先播放一个片段，然后我们会
surprise you with a couple of subsequent clips of the podcast. Okay, so it's early season two. Marshall has had his heartbroken. Lillian Marshall broke up at the end of season one. Marshall is tepidly trying to like tiptoe into being single. He's flirting with a woman at the coffee shop. They're actually hanging out at a coffee shop because he likes this woman who works there. And there's a debate about coffee shops versus bars. So I guess that decides it. Yep. Hanging out of the coffee place, not nearly as much fun as hanging out at a bar. Okay, so it goes on from there.
用播客的几个后续片段给你一个惊喜。好的，那是第二季初。马歇尔心碎了。莉莉和马歇尔在第一季末分手了。马歇尔正战战兢兢地试图试探着恢复单身。他在咖啡馆里和一个女人调情。他们实际上是在咖啡馆里闲逛，因为他喜欢在那里工作的那位女士。而且关于咖啡馆和酒吧之间还有一场辩论。所以我想这算是尘埃落定了。没错。在咖啡馆闲逛，可远不如在酒吧闲逛那么有趣。好了，接下来剧情就从这里展开了。
You see a flashback of Marshall flirting all week with this woman who works at the coffee shop, telling really stupid dad jokes, basically, but she's into it. And you kind of catch up to reality. He's going to ask her out. And they discover along the way that she drew a heart on his cup, but didn't do anything on Ted's cup. Well, what if the heart doesn't mean anything? What if she writes it on all the cups?
你会看到一个倒叙：马歇尔整整一周都在跟咖啡馆的这个女员工调情，基本上都是讲一些非常无聊的爸爸笑话，但她很吃这一套。然后镜头回到现实。他打算约她出去。在这个过程中他们发现，她在他的杯子上画了一个心，但对特德的杯子什么都没画。好吧，如果这个心没有什么特殊含义呢？如果她所有的杯子上都画了呢？
Mine says Ted, no heart. Mine says swarly. I think it's Swarly from Barney. It's not even a name. Who would ever be called Swarly? Oh, please don't start calling me Swarly. This would never happen at a bar. Man, what's up with Swarley?
我杯子上写的是特德，没有心。我杯子上写的是斯沃利。我觉得这是巴尼叫的“斯沃利”。这根本不是个名字。谁会叫斯沃利啊？哦，求求你们别开始叫我斯沃利了。这在酒吧里是绝对不会发生的。天哪，斯沃利怎么了？
I know. You almost never see old Swarles get that upset. Here's why I love that when we did this in 2006, I guess that heard. When we launched High Mitch Mother, we really wanted to separate ourselves from friends. We wanted to be able to say, we are not one of the 75 other shows that has tried to recapture what friends did.
我知道。你几乎从看不到老斯沃利发那么大脾气。这就是为什么我特别喜欢当年我们在2006年做这事的时候，我想大概是那个时候。当我们推出《老爸老妈浪漫史》时，我们真的很想把自己和《老友记》区分开来。我们希望能说，我们不是那另外75部试图重现《老友记》辉煌的剧集之一。
But of course, we look like friends. If you put it on a poster, it's like young people dating in New York. It looks similar. We wanted to differentiate ourselves. I thought this was a very clever way to do that because it seemed that opening joke about the coffee shop versus the bar.
但当然，我们看起来确实很像《老友记》。如果你把它印在海报上，它就像年轻人在纽约约会。看起来差不多。我们想要让自己与众不同。我认为这是一个非常巧妙的办法，因为开场那个关于咖啡馆和酒吧的笑话似乎……
Our home base set as a bar. It seemed obvious, and it was written by a friend's writer. Greg Malins, the only writer who wrote for friends and how I'm at your mother. And I thought that was such a great way to differentiate the two shows. Well, Greg came on our show recently on the podcast. Katu, 19 years later, and he revealed to me two big things that really undercut my feeling that had differentiated us from friends. One was his assertion, and he swears to God about this, that he did not mean it
我们的基地设定是一家酒吧。这似乎显而易见，而且它是由一位《老友记》的编剧写的。格雷格·马林斯，唯一一个既为《老友记》又为《老爸老妈浪漫史》写过剧本的编剧。我觉得这是区分这两部剧的绝佳方式。好吧，格雷格最近上了我们的播客节目。看图，19年之后，他向我透露了两件大事，彻底颠覆了我一直以来认为我们与《老友记》划清了界限的感觉。第一件事是他的断言，他对此向上帝发誓，他当时并不是有意把它
as a friend's versus how I met your mother joke. And literally every single person working on how much your mother, and the millions of people who've seen that episode, every single person thinks it's a friends differentiated from how I met your mother joke, except the guy who wrote it. He's like, no, I just thought it was like a funny line. Can I raise my hand on that one? When I watched it, I was like, oh, that's such a fun tongue and cheek. Oh, yeah. Like, wink to we're not friends in a coffee shop.
当成一个拿《老友记》对比《老爸老妈浪漫史》的梗。而且， literalmente（字面意思上）每一个在《老爸老妈浪漫史》剧组工作的人，以及看过那一集的几百万观众，每个人都觉得这是一个把《老友记》和《老爸老妈浪漫史》区分开来的梗，除了写下它的那个人。他觉得，不，我只是觉得这是一句挺搞笑的台词。我能在这一点上举个手吗？我当时看的时候就在想，哦，这太有趣了，真是一语双关、半开玩笑道。哦，对啊。就像是在眨眼暗示：我们可不是在咖啡馆里的《老友记》。
Right, right. I'll tell you, no way to answer. We all thought, this is a fun joke, dig it friends. Like, 100% everyone thought it. There's one guy on planet Earth who thinks it's not a friend's reference, and it's Greg Maylens. That is so crazy. Because also, like, there's the cute, like waitress, like barista, like kind of like Rachel. Like, wow, that's crazy. Greg, oh my lord. And the second thing that came out of that was even more disturbing. Greg made another confession about that last
对，对。我跟你说，完全没法反驳。我们所有人都觉得，这真是一个有趣的笑话，在致敬《老友记》呢。百分之百所有人都这么认为。地球上只有一个人觉得这不是在致敬《老友记》，那就是格雷格·马林斯。这太疯狂了。因为还有，里面那种可爱的女服务员、咖啡师，有点像瑞秋。天哪，这太疯狂了。格雷格，我的天啊。第二件爆出来的事更加让人震惊。格雷格对那个最后
joke right before you cut to titles that again, I was so proud that we were differentiating our show from the long shadow cast by friends. Well, 19 years later, a couple months ago, Greg Malins said this to me. Here's the truth, and I've never told anybody this. This is a revelation, and it's not something that A, I'm proud of, and B, makes me feel good, and C, makes me look good, because none of the above are true. The end of the cold open of this episode, I wrote that joke already on Friends.
就在进入片头字幕前的那个笑话又做出了另一个坦白，而我之前还为了我们成功让剧集摆脱《老友记》的长年阴影而感到无比骄傲。好吧，19年后的几个月前，格雷格·马林斯对我说过这样的话。事实是这样的，我从来没跟任何人说过。这是一个重磅内幕，而且A，我并不以此为傲；B，这让我感觉很不舒服；C，这让我显得很蠢，因为以上三点全都是真的。这一集寒暄开场的结尾，那个笑话我以前在《老友记》里就写过了。
Oh, my gosh. Yes. And while we're at it, can we play the clip of the joke on Friends? Which, again, I never knew until 2026. Okay, for now, temporarily. You can call me... Clint. No way are you cool enough to pull off Clint.
哦，天哪。没错。既然如此，我们能放一段《老友记》里那个笑话的剪辑吗？同样，我直到2026年才知道这件事。好吧，现在，暂时先这样。你可以叫我……克林特。你才没有酷到能驾驭克林特这个名字呢。
Okay, so what name am I cool enough to pull off? Um... Gene. It's Clint. It's clinked. See you later, Gene. It's clicked. Clicked! What's up with Gene? So you can see how this slay the undercuts my feeling that this was differentiating us from friends.
好吧，那我酷到能驾驭什么名字？嗯……吉恩。是克林特。是克林特。回头见，吉恩。是克林特。克林特！吉恩怎么了？所以你可以看到，这有多么动摇了我一直觉得这能让我们区别于《老友记》的感觉。
You're allowed to steal from yourself. I did a series with Greg after the office called Your Family or Mine on TBS. And now I want to rewatch it to see if there's any friends like sliding into your family or mine. He just keeps using them. Yeah. Maybe he puts him how much your mother jokes on that. He always takes the show previous and puts it on. But he was, I thought he was so noble.
你可以抄袭你自己嘛。我在《办公室》之后和格雷格一起在TBS做过一个系列剧叫《你的或是我的家庭》。现在我想重新看一遍，看看里面是不是有什么《老友记》式的元素滑进了《你的或是我的家庭》里。他一直在用这些梗。对啊。也许他把《老爸老妈浪漫史》的笑话也塞进去了。他总是拿前一部剧的梗放到新剧里。但我当时觉得他太高尚了。
And like there was something very brave about confessing to that 19 years later. That episode is a beloved, wonderful. episodes. Hamium fans go to coffee shops in 2026 and say the name Swirley. And they send us pictures of them doing the having had Swarly. Like that's an iconic episode written by Greg. He's a great writer. He did a great job in that episode. He slugged that one joke in figuring that we would beat it. And we never did. It got a huge laugh at the table rate. And you thought, oh, shit, this friend's joke's going to end up staying. It's going to stay. And the whole time I'm blabbering about, oh, I love that it differentiates us from friends. And in, you know, 20 years later,
而且19年后能坦白这件事，本身就非常勇敢。那一集是一部备受喜爱的、精彩绝伦的剧集。《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝们在2026年还会去咖啡馆说“斯沃利”这个名字。他们还会给我们发照片，展示他们模仿斯沃利的样子。就像那是格雷格写的一个标志性剧集一样。他是个伟大的编剧。他在那一集里表现得太棒了。他把那个笑话塞进去，本以为我们能推翻它。但我们从来没有。在剧本围读时它引来了哄堂大笑。然后你就会想，哦，操，这个《老友记》的梗看来是留得下了。它会留下的。而我一直在喋喋不休地说，哦，我喜欢这个梗，它把我们和《老友记》区分开了。结果在，你知道的，20年之后，
I learned it did not differentiate us from friends in any way. That's great. Awesome, guys. And look at all the things you're discovering through the podcast, through the rewatch, you know? How fun is that? Yeah. Love it. Are you guys loving it?
我才知道它在任何方面都没有把我们和《老友记》区分开。太棒了。太棒了，伙计们。看看你们通过播客、通过重温节目发现了多少东西，你知道吗？多有趣啊。对啊。太棒了。你们喜欢吗？
Are you loving the experience, Josh, of having to watch it? And is your wife still watching with you? She is. Yes. Although I think I might have mentioned this to you. She's dying because she wants to just keep going. She just wants to binge. And we have to dole it out.
乔治，你喜欢这种必须看剧的体验吗？你太太现在还在跟你一起看吗？她在看。是的。不过我想我之前可能跟你提过。她快急死了，因为她只想一直看下去。她只想一口气刷完。而我们不得不一集一集挤牙膏似地看。
And I have to watch them in order. and she can't run out ahead of me, so she's having to wait on you. So she doesn't like that. But other than that, she's having a great time. And it's so nice to watch it with her and to let her see this huge part of my life before I met her, having a different perspective on it all these years later, which is what the show is kind of framed as a man looking back on his life when he was younger. And so it's just been a blast.
而且我必须按顺序看。她不能跑在我前面，所以她只能等我。所以她不太喜欢这样。但除此之外，她看得非常开心。和她一起看剧，让她看到我认识她之前我生命中的这巨大一部分，在所有这些年之后对这一切有了一种不同的视角，这感觉真的很美好。这部剧的设定本来就是一个男人回首自己年轻时的生活。所以这简直是一段无比美妙的经历。
And, you know, like we talked about before, but hearing from fans and also, learning about myself now versus then and where I was then and kind of forgiving myself for how hard I was on myself then. And it's just, I don't know, the whole thing has been like quite a blessing. So we're really thrilled. Oh my goodness. Josh Craig, thank you so much for coming on to talk about cold opens with us. Y'all are such a delight. We enjoy you so much. You got to come back. Please. Yeah, we'd love to have you back on our show. We love hanging with you guys. Yeah, thank you guys so much. Thanks for taking us under your wing and showing us how to do a podcast. We're thrilled to be paired with you guys.
而且，正如我们之前谈到的，听到粉丝们的反馈，也了解了现在的我和过去的我的对比，以及我当时处在什么状态，并有点原谅自己当年对自己那么苛刻。总之，我不知道，整件事就像是一种巨大的祝福。所以我们真的非常激动。噢天哪。乔治、克雷格，非常感谢你们来跟我们聊聊冷开场。你们俩太招人喜欢了。我们太喜欢你们了。你们一定要再来。拜托。对，我们很乐意邀请你们再来我们的节目。我们超喜欢和你们一起玩。对，非常感谢你们。谢谢你们把我们领进门，教我们怎么做播客。能跟你们搭档我们感到非常激动。
Thanks for having us. Next time, tags. Yeah, man. Bring on the tags. We'll define what tags are. We'll have a whole philosophical discussion. Good times. Love you guys.
谢谢邀请。下次聊标签。对啊，伙计。把标签整上。我们要定义一下什么是标签。我们要进行一场宏大的哲学讨论。好时光。爱你们，伙计们。
Thanks for having us, you guys. Thank you so much. Bye. Bye. Well, I love those guys. I mean, they're smart, they're funny, they're insightful. I mean, come on. And kind and warm.
谢谢你们邀请我们，伙计们。非常感谢。拜拜。拜拜。我真是太喜欢这几个家伙了。我是说，他们聪明、幽默、有见地。我是说，真的。而且善良又温暖。
And kind. I know. Lovely. Lovely. Love them. go check out their podcast, How We Made Your Mother. And now, folks, it's time for... Our first Around the Town is from Jesse P in Chesterland, Ohio. Jesse says,
而且善良。我懂。可爱。可爱。爱死他们了。快去听听他们的播客《我们是怎么创造你妈妈的》。好了，各位，现在是时候……我们今天的第一个“走遍小镇”栏目来自俄亥俄州切斯特兰的杰西·P。杰西说：
My family is in our third year of making our own maple syrup from the red maple trees on our property. My husband spends every Saturday in March boiling down sap in his homemade evaporator. We make enough for our family for the whole year and a little extra for friends. Our kids no longer like store-bought maple syrup and won't even touch, quote, pancake syrup anymore, laughing face.
我们家已经连续三年用我们地里的红枫树自制枫糖浆了。我丈夫三月份的每个星期六都在他自制的蒸发器里熬制树液。我们做的量足够全家吃整整一年，还能多出来一点送给朋友。我们的孩子们再也不喜欢买来的枫糖浆了，甚至连所谓的“煎饼糖浆”碰都不碰，（笑脸）。
That is so cool. This tells you how much I know about maple syrup. I didn't realize that Ohio had red maple trees. I mean, of course, right? I mean, we have maple trees in Missouri. I guess I didn't think you could get syrup from them. I mean, I don't even know how you get the syrup. Do you?
这太酷了。这说明我对枫糖浆的了解有多匮乏。我以前不知道俄亥俄州有红枫树。我是说，当然有了，对吧？我是说，我们在密苏里州也有枫树。我猜我只是没想到你能从它们身上提取糖浆。我是说，我甚至不知道你是怎么搞到糖浆的。你知道吗？
This is a crazy question. Do you put like a spigot in the tree? I mean, I don't know. I think you spicket the tree. Is that crazy? Did I see that in a movie? Was that a cartoon? Was that like a Bugs Bunny cartoon I saw in the youth?
这是一个疯狂的问题。你是往树里插个龙头吗？我是说，我不知道。我觉得你是往树里插个龙头。这很疯狂吗？我是我在电影里看到的吗？那是动画片吗？那是像我小时候看的兔八哥动画片吗？
I don't know because I feel like I saw a spiket in a tree too, but I don't know why. Maybe was it in a movie or something? I don't know. Okay, yes. Well, according to the internet, a spigot or a spile is used to tap maple trees for sap, usually from February to March. Well, there you go. For whatever reason, I just thought all the syrup was coming from Canada. I never allowed syrup to come from anywhere else. I'm sorry, Ohio. This is wonderful. I wish we were neighbors with you, Jesse, so we could trade. I would
我不知道，因为我觉得我也在树上见过一个龙头，但我不知道为什么。也许是在电影里什么的？我不知道。好吧，是的。根据互联网的说法，人们会在2月到3月期间，在枫树上打孔并插入一个龙头或导管来收集树液。好吧，原来如此。不管出于什么原因，我以前一直以为所有的糖浆都来自加拿大。我从不容许糖浆来自其他任何地方。对不起，俄亥俄州。这太棒了。我真希望我们能和你做邻居，杰西，这样我们就能做交换了。我愿意
like give you some lemons for some of your syrup. Right. Our next around the town is from Heidi Jay, who said, my friend's pet Dotson, Walter Pickles, won first place this. last weekend at the Canterbury Park, 2026 Winter Dog Race for Wiener Dogs. His description on the lineup sheet said, Walter Pickles is a very social-friendly mini-dotson. He loves chasing bunnies and squirrels and taking long sniff walks. His favorite human food treat is popcorn. Aw, congratulations, Walter Pickles. That is adorable.
用一些柠檬来换你的一些糖浆。没错。我们下一个“走遍小镇”栏目来自海蒂·J，她说：我朋友的宠物腊肠犬“沃尔特·泡菜”在上周末举行的坎特伯雷公园2026年冬季腊肠犬赛跑中赢得了第一名。他在参赛名单上的描述是：“沃尔特·泡菜”是一只非常社交友好、体型微小的腊肠犬。他喜欢追逐兔子和松鼠，喜欢进行漫长而充满嗅探的散步。他最喜欢的人类食物零食是爆米花。啊，祝贺沃尔特·泡菜。太可爱了。
I want to see the Winter Dog Race for Wiener Dogs. got to be the cutest thing. All right. Next up, and oh my goodness, did this one make my heart happy. It's from Kate W. in Chattanooga, who wrote in and said she was so inspired by the office ladies breakdown of the paper and our shout out to my grandmother, Lena May, in her newspaper column that she started a local newspaper of her own called the Chattie Nugans. Get it? To highlight the everyday lives of the people in the people in the same. their town. The first issue just went live at the beginning of March and featured work from local artists, a growing tie collection, an escape room crawl, and a goth-themed train ride. You can check out the first issue. It's on their Instagram, the chatty underscore Nugans, and she also went on to say a big thank you to us for being part of the inspiration behind this passion project.
我想去看冬季腊肠犬赛跑。那绝对是最可爱的东西。好的。接下来，天哪，这个故事让我的内心感到无比幸福。它来自查塔努加的凯特·W，她写信说，她深受《办公室女士》对纸张的剖析以及我们在专栏中对我的祖母莉娜·梅的致敬的启发，于是她创办了自己的当地报纸，名叫《查蒂·努根斯》（Chattie Nugans）。懂了吗？为了突出他们镇上普通人的日常生活。第一期刚在三月份上线，内容包括当地艺术家的作品、不断增长的领带收藏、密室逃脱大串联以及哥特主题的火车之旅。你可以去看看第一期。就在他们的Instagram账号chatty_Nugans上，她还接着对我们表达了巨大的感谢，谢谢我们成为了这个充满热情的项目背后的灵感来源之一。
This fills my heart with so much joy. I love this. I love this for your grandma. I love this for the chatty Nugans. It makes me happy. It made me so happy. I just thought of my grandmother, you know, if she would have never even imagined that something like this is possible, that her little around the town column would just be touching other people's lives like this. Oh my goodness, Kate, thank you for sharing that. That's legacy, right? This has now become part of your grandmother's legacy. It continues to grow. She can continues to reach people. It's really cool. It's so cool. All right. And we always now in these episodes with our office question of the week. This one comes from Catherine R from Mississippi.
这让我的内心充满了无尽的欢乐。我太喜欢这个了。我为你的祖母感到高兴。我为《查蒂·努根斯》感到高兴。这让我太开心了。这真的让我太开心了。我刚才想到了我的祖母，你知道的，她绝对从未想象过这样的事情是可能的，她小小的“走遍小镇”专栏竟然能像这样触动其他人的生活。噢天哪，凯特，谢谢你分享这个。这就是精神遗产，对吧？这现在已经成为了你祖母精神遗产的一部分。它还在继续成长。她还在继续触动人们。这真的很酷。太酷了。好了。我们现在总是在这些节目结束时以我们的“每周办公室问答”收尾。这个提问来自密西西比州的凯瑟琳·R。
Catherine says, which episode of the office was your favorite to film? And why is it your favorite? Oh, Catherine, this is so difficult. I love this question because I feel like we're always asking our guests this question. But I wondered, have we answered this question? I've been asked this question before in interviews, and I have a few answers because there's sort of the episode that was my favorite to film because of maybe stuff that happened on set behind the scenes that are just special to me, but then there were episodes that were just so incredibly funny or creative or interesting that those were really fun to shoot too. But Angela, do you have an answer?
凯瑟琳问：《办公室》里你最喜欢拍摄哪一集？为什么这是你最喜欢的一集？哦，凯瑟琳，这太难选了。我喜欢这个问题，因为我觉得我们总是在问我们的嘉宾这个问题。但我想知道，我们回答过这个问题吗？我在采访中以前被问过这个问题，我有几个答案，因为有些集是我最喜欢拍的，可能是因为幕后发生了一些对我来说很特别的事情，但还有一些集是纯粹因为太好笑、太有创意或太有趣，所以拍起来也非常过瘾。不过，安吉拉，你有什么答案吗？
This is really, I mean, Catherine, I feel like. like this changes for me every couple of months because, you know, Jenna and I rewatch the whole show and then every once in a while I'll catch an episode with the kids or something or it will pop up, you know, like you're traveling, you're in a hotel room, you're like, oh, the office is on Comedy Central. I'll watch one. And this might surprise you, Jenna. But I was feeling very nostalgic recently for beach games. Oh, that doesn't surprise me. I mean, that was a hard shoot. Is that why you think it would surprise me? Because it was a little grueling.
这真的，我是说，凯瑟琳，我觉得。这个答案对我来说每隔几个月就会变一次，因为，你知道的，詹娜和我重温整部剧，然后每隔一段时间我会和孩子们一起看某一集，或者它偶然出现，你知道的，就像你出差在酒店房间里，你会想，哦，喜剧中心频道正在播《办公室》呢。我会看一集。这可能会让你感到意外，詹娜。但我最近对《海滩游戏》感到非常怀旧。哦，这并不让我意外。我是说，那是一场很艰难的拍摄。这就是你觉得会让我意外的原因吗？因为那有点折磨人。
It was grueling. We were outside in the heat. It was like dusty and sandy and like we got sunburned. It was long days. But then at night it was freezing, but we had to be in our same clothes that we had. That was the thing about beach games. You established this warm weather clothing for the day. And then at night you were stuck with that same outfit and you were freezing.
那确实很折磨人。我们在户外顶着高温拍摄。又多尘又多沙，而且我们都被晒伤了。那是漫长的一天。但到了晚上又冷得要命，而我们还得穿着白天拍戏时穿的同一套衣服。《海滩游戏》就是这样。你白天确立了这身适合暖和天气的服装。到了晚上你就只能穿着这同一套衣服，冻得瑟瑟发抖。
And you were freezing, yeah. So it was physically a difficult shoot. But, you know, I was going through some old people. pictures and it was so just special in so many ways. Okay, one, I loved my storyline with letting Andy just float away. And I love that line where I say, did you say sandwich and Dwight says sabotage. I remember Jen Salada laughing her butt off and almost ruining a take because she cracked up every single time I said, did you say sandwich? But then I also just remember us hanging out in between scenes by our trailers. We had like a little camp they set up and someone brought a football and
而且冻得瑟瑟发抖，对。所以从体力上来说这是一场艰难的拍摄。但是，你知道的，我最近在翻看一些老照片，它在很多方面都太特别了。好吧，第一，我太喜欢我和安迪的那条故事线了，看着他随风飘走。我特别喜欢那句台词，我说：“你刚刚说三明治吗？”然后德怀特说：“蓄意破坏。”我记得詹娜·萨拉达当时笑得前仰后合，差点毁了一条镜头，因为每次我说“你刚才说三明治吗”的时候她都会笑喷。但我也同样记得我们在两场戏之间在我们的房车旁边闲逛。我们就像搭了一个小型营地，有人带了一个美式足球来，
we were throwing the football and Harold Ramos came over in the morning and we would all have coffee together and sit outside one of the trailers having our coffee talking in the morning. It's just, it's amazing to me that I got to be a part of all of that. And I would say not to be totally sappy, but I am a bit of a sap. One of the things that was. One of the things that was really special to me about it, was watching you as my best friend have this absolutely amazing monologue that had so much. It was so long. I remember when we got the script, it was like half a page. And you nailed it in front of all of us and it had all this emotion. And I was so proud of you. Anyway, I don't know. I've just been very nostalgic for that episode. What a wonderful memory
我们在那里扔美式足球，哈罗德·拉莫斯早上会过来，我们大家一起喝咖啡，坐在其中一辆房车外面一边喝咖啡一边在清晨聊天。这对我来说太神奇了，我竟然能成为这一切的一部分。而且我得说——不是为了显得太伤感，但我确实有点多愁善感。其中一件事是。其中一件事对我来说真的很特别，就是看着你作为我最好的朋友，发表了一段绝对精彩的独白，里面包含了如此丰富的情感。那段词太长了。我记得当我们拿到剧本时，那大概有半页纸。你在我们所有人面前完美地完成了它，包含了那么多的情感。我为你感到无比骄傲。总之，我不知道。我只是对那一集充满了怀旧之情。多么美好的回忆啊。
I really hold it close to my heart. It's so funny that you picked that one, Angela, and for the reasons that you picked it, because there were two episodes that popped into my mind and they're one right after the other in season two. And the first one is Booz Cruise. And again, you'd be like, why are you picking the episode where we were up until the crack of dawn
我真的把它深深地记在心里。安吉拉，你选了那一集，而且是因为你所说的那些原因，这太有趣了，因为有两集闪入了我的脑海，而且它们在第二季里是紧挨着播出的。第一集就是《酒水游轮》。而且同样，你可能会想，你为什么要选那一集？我们在那一集里熬到了破晓时分，
and we were all nauseous and you got lost at sea? But, you know, it's that thing where those memories are now part of the lore and the joy of the show. They're part of the adventure of it. And we all really bonded. And that was the episode, Angela, where you guys found out you were going to be series regulars. Yeah. And so there was that extra added celebration and joy to that episode. But then it was also just really funny.
而且我们都晕船了，你还在海上迷路了？但是，你知道的，这就是那种情况：这些记忆现在已经成了这部剧的传说和欢乐的一部分。它们是这场冒险的一部分。我们所有人都真正地凝聚在了一起。而且那一集，安吉拉，就是你们发现自己要成为剧组常驻演员的那一集。对。所以那一集多了一层额外的庆祝和喜悦。但同时它也真的超级搞笑。
It was fun being stuck together. It was like a summer camp at sea, you know? Mm-hmm. And we all got to stay in a hotel, even though we never saw each other, except on the boat, because we were all so tired. And then, you know, the next episode after that was the injury. And I remember this was when we were finally not worried we were going to be canceled every single week. Yeah.
大家挤在一起拍戏很有意思。就像海上的夏令营一样，你知道吗？嗯。而且我们所有人都得住在一家酒店里，尽管除了在船上之外我们几乎见不到彼此，因为大家都累坏了。然后，你知道的，接下来的那一集就是《受伤》。我记得这是我们终于不用每周都担心被砍的时候了。对。
And I think we could exhale a little bit. You guys were series regulars. And then Mindy wrote this script that was just so bonkers and weird. and so funny, and I laughed so hard shooting that episode with Steve and the butter and all of his antics with the bubble wrap. The bubble wrap. Yeah. So that section right there, those are some of my fondest memories.
我想我们可以稍微松一口气了。你们都成了常驻演员。然后明迪写了这个剧本，简直是太疯狂、太古怪了，又超级搞笑，我和史蒂夫一起拍那一集时笑得肚子疼，还有黄油以及他用气泡膜搞出的那些恶作剧。气泡膜。对。所以就在那个部分，那些是我最美好的回忆。
Yeah. I mean, obviously, I have favorite ones because I loved us all in the conference room, and we would get so punchy. So I look back on episodes where at the time, I was like, I cannot believe we're spending five. days in this one room together, this one tiny conference room. But those are the ones, though, that feel so special, because we were all sort of in it together, you know? Yes. Yes. I feel like if someone said, okay, I'm going to send you back in time and you get to reshoot one episode. You get to re-experience shooting one. I think I would choose the injury because it's in the bullpen. Yeah. You know, I would want to go back in time and be in the bullpen. Right. And,
对啊。我是说，显然，我有我最喜欢的几集，因为我喜欢我们所有人都在会议室里的戏份，我们会变得特别起劲。所以我回想起那些集的时候，当时我简直不敢相信我们竟然在这个房间里、在这个狭小的会议室里度过了整整五天。但正是那些时刻感觉如此特别，因为我们某种程度上都在一起经历这一切，你知道吗？对。对。我觉得如果有人说：“好吧，我要把你送回过去，你可以重新拍摄一集。你可以重新体验拍摄一集。”我想我会选择《受伤》，因为它发生在开放式办公区。对。你知道的，我想回到过去，待在开放式办公区里。对。而且，
And I just remember laughing so hard and it was so absurd. And we were all like still very young and fresh. And we were experimenting and we were finding ourselves. And that's just such an exciting time creatively. That's such a great question. If I could go back and relive one. I mean, that's really hard to pick because I loved dinner party, but I would want to redo one with everybody. Yeah. In the office, right? In the office. And I was thinking, gosh, selfishly I would also love women's appreciation. Those scenes of us in that van and marred this van with all the trash and junk in it. And, you know, we got to spend a whole day with Steve.
我只记得当时笑得太厉害了，而且太荒谬了。我们当时都还很年轻、很有活力。我们在不断尝试，在寻找自我。在创作上，那真是一个令人兴奋的时期。这真是一个好问题。如果我可以回去重新经历一遍。我是说，这真的很难选，因为我太喜欢《晚宴派对》了，但我会想和大家一起重拍一集。对。在办公室里，对吧？在办公室里。我当时在想，天哪，自私地说，我也很想拍《女性致敬》。我们在那辆面包车里的那些场景，面包车里塞满了垃圾和破烂。而且，你知道的，我们和史蒂夫一起度过了整整一天。
We got to have Steve to ourselves. And that was so fun. And of course, you know, we had scenes in the office too, so we would get to be with everyone. But I would do that day again for sure. Yeah. Yeah. Aw. Well, thanks, Catherine.
我们能独占史蒂夫。那太有趣了。当然，你知道的，我们在办公室里也有戏份，所以我们能和所有人在一起。但如果能再过那样一天，我绝对愿意。对。对。啊。好吧，谢谢你，凯瑟琳。
Thanks for letting us answer that question that we've asked so many people ourselves. It's fun to think about. Yeah. And thank you guys so much for writing in. We're really just loving doing these segments with you all. So go to OfficeLadies.com. You can click on submit a question. We have lots of fun folders where you can write in.
谢谢你让我们回答了那个我们自己问过无数人的问题。思考这些真的很有趣。对。非常感谢你们写信来。我们真的超级喜欢和大家一起做这些环节。所以请访问OfficeLadies.com。你可以点击“提交问题”。我们有很多有趣的文件夹供你写信投稿。
Yeah, we've gotten really organized, everybody. We did it. We're very grateful to Ileana who helps us with our website. We have a special folder for Second Drinks, where we want you to go in there and tell us your favorite moments from episodes. And then we also have a folder for Around the Town for chit-chat questions and now officially a folder for the office question of the week. Yeah, so go check it out. And we hope you guys have the best week. We appreciate you all so much. And a big thank you to Craig Thomas and Josh Radnor for joining us today. We'll see you next week, everyone.
对，大家，我们现在真的变得很有条理了。我们做到了。非常感谢伊莱亚娜，她一直在帮我们打理网站。我们有一个专门存放“第二轮饮品”的文件夹，我们希望你们去那里告诉我们你们在剧中最喜欢的时刻。然后我们还有一个用于“走遍小镇”闲聊问题的文件夹，现在正式增设了一个“每周办公室问答”的文件夹。对，所以快去看看吧。希望大家都有个美好的一周。我们非常感激你们。非常感谢克雷格·托马斯和乔治·雷德纳今天加入我们。大家下周见。
See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle, and our audio engineer is Sam Keefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本期节目由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。主题曲是克里·布拉顿创作的《Ruppertry》。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。